el 2020 empató con 2016 como el año más
caluroso jamás registrado así lo
constató el informe anual de copernicus
el servicio europeo para la vigilancia
del cambio climático consolidando la
década del 2010 al 2020 como la más
calurosa de la historia la región más
afectada fue el ártico con más de 6
grados por encima de la media cuando nos
fijamos sólo en un año aisladamente por
supuesto que no es un indicador del
cambio climático pero sin esta tendencia
las temperaturas no habrían sido tan
altas como lo fueron en 2020 2019 y los
años anteriores en efecto los últimos
seis años han batido el récord de los
más calurosos
con poco más de un grado de
calentamiento hasta el momento el mundo
ya ha presenciado sequías olas de calor
lluvias intensas e incendios altamente
destructivos que los expertos avisan
empeorarán si los países y empresas no
reducen drásticamente las emisiones de
gas el 2020 alcanzó un número récord de
huracanes en el atlántico y contó con
grandes incendios en el ártico y otras
regiones del mundo
dando grandes cantidades de dióxido de
carbono a la atmósfera la extensión de
hielo del ártico y los glaciares se
agotaron notablemente el pronóstico no
ha mejorado a pesar de la reducción de
gases en un 7% por la pandemia todavía
estamos añadiendo a la atmósfera porque
no son las emisiones lo que cuentan es
la concentración al final así que
incluso si cortamos las emisiones un
poco ese poco se sigue añadiendo a la
atmósfera
la clave es cada año y lo más rápido
posible reducir la cantidad que emitimos
y se añade a la atmósfera
vernet e incluso si todas las naciones
cumplen con las promesas climáticas del
acuerdo de parís de 2015 el planeta se
calentará más de 3 grados para el final
del siglo